hi everyone my name is sai venom and I'm
a developer advocate with IBM today I
want to talk about hybrid cloud if
you're watching this video then you're
probably tasked with a very important
role of figuring out how hybrid cloud
fits in with your company's architecture
or maybe you're just a little bit
curious about this cloud computing
approach either way essentially hybrid
cloud boils down into a mixture of a
private as well as a public environment
and essentially the two are working in
tandem to run your workloads and
applications to better explain hybrid
cloud I want to start with an example
let's say we've got a fictional company
Acme freight who is essentially tasked
with you know running shipments Acme
freight has an existing on-premise
application an ERP application which
many people might be familiar with is an
enterprise resource planning app which
enables them to manage their shipments
and make sure that they make it there on
time but let's say that this ERP
application is made up of three major
sections we've got the BFF in the middle
here we've got the chunk of the ERP
application that kind of runs things
like in inventory truck drivers
deliveries shipments that kind of thing
and we've got the at the bottom here a
user registry human resources that kind
of thing so the BFF is going to
basically handle any time front-end
requests are made to make sure that web
dashboard looks great but Acme Freight
has just created a new mobile
application that needs a new BFF
application to actually serve those
endpoints so to do that the team decided
to create a new BFF layer on the public
side so they've started with a new
public cloud and they've decided to
deploy the back-end for this mobile
application on this cloud so we've got
the mobile bf
application here so the main thing to
keep in mind here so only the mobile BFF
application is running in the public
cloud so they still need a way for this
to interact with the existing ERP app to
do so they'll simply open up a tunnel
that allows the mobile BFF application
to work with those private endpoints
that the ERP application serves so
that's one of the key tenants of a
hybrid cloud environment is the fact
that they must be interoperable
essentially meaning that the public
components and the private components
are working in tandem so so far the
truck delivery drivers are loving this
new infrastructure they're able to use
their mobile apps to kind of submit
whenever a delivery is made but what
they've noticed is during the holiday
season or peak hours this whole system
is bogging down and is leading to
delivered deliveries that are late and
shipments that are being missed to
tackle this Acme Freight decides you
know what it's about time we need to
start breaking this model like monolith
down so they decide to move the ERP
portion the big chunk break it apart
into micro services and move it to a
public cloud to do so they take
advantage of Linux container
technologies things like docker as well
as container orchestration management
tools like kubernetes and successfully
they move that ERP layer to the public
cloud not an easy task so we can imagine
that there's a number of micro services
that represent that ERP application that
are running in a public cloud and
they're working with docker technology
and Kupa kubernetes technology keeping
everything orchestrated and scaled out
that's one of the great things about
taking advantage of a public cloud is
that there's seemingly endless
public resources to to scale out your
application so although they get to keep
their existing on-premise or ERP
architecture they start moving to the
public cloud and take advantage of the
scalability and the capabilities that
are offered
there another advantage of working with
the public cloud you're no longer locked
into a specific vendor traditionally
with monolithic applications maybe
you're working with a Java EE stack
you're you're kind of forced to use the
capabilities that the stack allows you
to use but with public cloud you can
kind of go window-shopping there's lots
of open source projects out there
programming languages that you can use
and with micro-services speaking on
public interfaces you know all of those
services can talk to one another
regardless of the technology that
they're written in so definitely by
taking advantage of the public cloud
they get to use cool third-party
services so Acme Freight decides you
know we can do better with delivery
rerouting whenever there is a snowstorm
or inclement weather and so to do that
they hook up this ERP application to
Watson and take advantage of some of the
cognitive capabilities to power delivery
rerouting so effectively where there
were taken advantage of the portability
features offered by taking on a hybrid
cloud architecture the last thing I want
to touch on is security
although Acme Freid moved over the
mobile BFF piece as well as the ERP
application and to micro services and
you know in a perfect world maybe
they've even phased out these two
portions they continue to keep the user
registry on Prem because that's
something that they want to keep
firewall they want to keep it completely
secure and always on their own
infrastructure and hardware that's one
of the great advantages of hybrid cloud
is that they can continue to keep
certain resources firewalled and on Prem
while taking advantage of the public
cloud to continue to run their
applications and workloads so together
hybrid clouds you get the features of
interoperability scalability portability
as well as security all of these come
together to enable developers and
companies to take advantage of the best
of both worlds when running their
applications if you want to learn more
about hybrid cloud check out the
accompanying links or the IBM cloud blog